hello everyone my name is bradley and
welcome to our weekly show where we talk
about some of the juiciest hanging
fruits of the online jungle now i must
admit i love computer games especially
aaa projects you know with
photorealistic graphics a powerful plot
and really dynamic action that's why i
remember 2013 perfectly together with my
friends i spent hundreds of hours on the
streets of los santos from gta 5
uncovered all the secrets of flying
columbia and bioshock infinites and i
saved ellie more than once in the last
of us and i'm sure that you remember
these games too
but then at the age of 15 i couldn't
even imagine that 10 years later
simply unremarkable sandbox game with
primitive graphics could explode on the
scene and shake up the entire gaming
industry
in 2013 when this game was released on
ios devices i didn't hear a word about
it but now in 2022 its name haunts me in
articles about metaverses and videos
about the black market of digital items
in stock exchange news harassment
investigations the word is becoming
increasingly common
roblox
if you don't know what it is ask your
children
i mean among american teenagers roblox
overtook youtube in popularity five
years ago and today i'm going to try to
understand how seriously its creators
take the digital security of their users
now this is a very
you know topical and sensitive issue
given that two-thirds of roblox users
are children and teenagers under the age
of 16. so let's take a look at this
platform through the eyes of a cyber
security expert
[Music]
now in the spring of 2021 a newcomer
broke into the ratings of the most
expensive gaming companies and
immediately overtook ubisoft take two
and even ea
on the day of going public roblox's
shares were valued at 45 billion dollars
and in the summer its value exceeded 50
billion but look this is hardly
surprising 200 million people visit
roblox servers every month roblox is
often compared to minecraft but this is
a mistake minecraft is an open world
game a sandbox in which the player can
create buildings fortresses and even
cities from simple blocks roblox it's
more like youtube it's a platform for
creating your own content games and also
a tool for generating income you can't
do that with minecraft now
in roblox's studio you can create
virtual worlds and form your own
multiplayer games from platformers to
racing simulators users have a simple
interface and a large number of
ready-made blocks at their disposal now
their behavior is described by basic lua
scripts but everything's so simple and
intuitive so creating a small arcade
that can just take a couple of hours so
it's no shock that users have already
created more than 20 million games and
they're not going to stop anytime soon
after all once created your game can
become a source of real money any game
can include a payment system using
microtransactions the platform's own
currency robux is used for payments the
income from the sale of virtual items is
divided between developers of a
particular game and the creators the
platform and this is a huge market
reminiscent of this upcoming metaverse
reality i mean the total revenue from
purchases has already exceeded two
billion dollars
just imagine for a second 200 million
children and teenagers gathering in one
place every month with hundreds of
millions of dollars in pocket money
of course this could not fail to attract
the attention of criminals let's take a
look at what they can expect and to do
this i'm actually going to create a new
profile in
the roblox
now sounds a bit funny but let's give it
a go
[Music]
so look i'm going to use a pseudonym
that i came up with in a video about
creating a new identity let's say
jack
duke
taylor
right
seems that name is already taken
what about
duke taylor
nope
um okay well let's do jack underscored
jack underscore duke underscored
taylor only one underscore can be used
in the name
uh
i mean to be honest this is the first
time i see such a restriction
anyway i'll try and shorten something
like j underscore d taylor
right good
okay the next stage is to create a
password now this is quite interesting
because the password well it usually
requires you to
put the same thing twice in a row right
to avoid typos but here the interfaces
deliberately simplified it's enough to
enter the password only once to get in
i wonder if it will be possible to
recover a forgotten or incorrectly
written password
by the way there is actually a check for
matching the password with the username
that's something i'd like to see
now it's not necessary to specify the
gender but i am still going to click on
the right button here now consent to the
terms of use and security policy is
issued automatically by simply clicking
on the sign up button how many teenagers
do you think are going to read and
understand
10 paragraphs a page on 16 pages of a
document
yeah they probably won't even click on
these links to be honest however now i
have to verify
i wonder if i'll need any documents or
tokens
well i doubt it very much
so
well this is a simple analog of the
reverse turing test capture its purpose
is just to confirm that i'm a real
person and not a bot so there's no real
verification of identity or age yeah
okay so now i'm the lucky owner of a
roblox gaming account and the first
thing i see on my profile is a store of
elements from which my avatar is created
yes some basic parts are free but the
vast majority are sold for money or
rather for roebucks
i wonder how many real dollars a virtual
jacket will cost me
so to buy the local currency i have to
spend at least
4.99 and here is a possible issue i
talked about in that video on friendly
fraud
what do you think which of these buttons
is clicked more often white or green
even adults often make this mistake they
click on a more profitable looking and
bright offer as a result they subscribe
instead of making a one-time purchase
and it's difficult to notice a monthly
write off five dollars especially if
this operation only needs to be
confirmed after the first time if you
notice such outgoings in your statement
don't rush to contact the bank for a
chargeback this will put you on the same
level as the scammers the issue with
randomly issued subscriptions should be
solved with the service the bank has
absolutely nothing to do with it but the
problem is the developers of roblox
described in detail the mechanism for
returning money in this situation and
i'll leave a link to that article in the
description of this video another
important point here is to check the
settings in your itunes account google
play and amazon you can actually buy
these robux or subscribe through these
services
well if i'm willing to say spoon out
five dollars on some robux then each
individual robux will cost about 1.20
turns out that i can buy a jacket for
about one and a half to two dollars the
t-shirt will cost 1.20 and you have to
add another 140 for the pants more
expensive than i predicted but in
principle quite acceptable compared to
rare items in world of warcraft or
spaceships on eve online well these are
pennies stop
it seems that i've spent almost my
entire supply of robux in the first few
minutes without even launching a single
game
now i'm starting to understand where
that two billion dollar turnover comes
from and look roblox is notorious for
cases where children have spent huge
sums of money for example six-year-old
christian from canberra managed to spend
eight thousand dollars on virtual
shopping now christian's parents managed
to get the money back but it's still
better not to become a victim of family
fraud at all the good news is that you
can set for your child or yourself a
limit on the amount of purchases in
roblox don't ignore this feature because
there are some very amazing and tempting
things in the store of items and clothes
just look at this if you go on the tab
with the full list of available products
and select sorting by price and i can't
believe my eyes items are sold here for
999 199 and 999 robots that is their
real value is more than a billion
dollars
okay i see it's just the desire of some
creators to attract attention to
themselves of course no one's actually
going to buy anything for that kind of
money however a quick cursory search on
thematic resources showed that unlimited
items can reach up to 50 000 robux and
unique collectibles for example the
domino crown up to 50 million i think i
once said something about the fact that
nft art is an ideal tool for money
laundering right well with the creators
account in the game you can sell items
and things to any other players at any
price point without expertise or
auctions or unnecessary noise and this
is just the tip of the iceberg
developers can introduce their own
currencies and unique items into their
games however the earnings will have to
be shared with the creators of the
platform
according to the people make games
channel game authors receive less than
25 of funds from internal transactions
the remaining 75 goes to the creators of
roblox well look let's finally launch a
popular game so you can actually see how
safe this is going to be for young
children
now i'm going to start with a seemingly
harmless adopt me game this is one of
the most popular games it seems on the
platform and it has been played almost
30 billion times
30 billion
i mean clue there's not even any
violence fights or indecent content on
this game it's weird initially it was
developed as a simplified simulator of
families with foster children later the
emphasis changed to raising and looking
after pets
at the beginning of the game you get an
egg which you sort of need to take care
of so that a pet will eventually hatch
out of it at the same time you can walk
around the game's world complete simple
tasks and local currency and you can
also communicate with other people so
it's something like a cocktail of
tamagotchi and pokemon in the open world
right
now virtual pets become the target of
real scammers and it's clear to see that
the fact is the price of rare pets is
measured in hundreds of real dollars the
official price of frost fury is 800
roblox
but they sell for much much more however
scammers real scammers are hunting
mainly for less expensive pets whose
owners are children seven to eight years
old they tried to start a dialogue
inside the game and offer lucrative
deals now there are many options for
cheating in adopt me but these are all
based on simple social engineering
tactics scammers can actually ask a
child to help make a video for youtube
and to do this you actually need to hand
over your pet for one minute or so
and sometimes they offer the services of
a babysitter or a trainer for an animal
sometimes they complain about software
failures and ask to transfer another pet
and sometimes they simply beg in the
parental control settings you can
actually prohibit your child from
chatting with other players but i don't
think you should do that because well
it's probably the most useful part of
the game here i mean let the child face
real scammers and find out that not all
people should be trusted you can't just
tell them that sometimes and a lost
virtual pet is a small price to pay for
such an important fundamental lesson in
life oh my gosh
she scammed me she scammed me oh my god
i'm gonna cry
i think i get scammed way too much in
roblox and someone
this is so stupid
you should also explain to the child
that you shouldn't participate in
suspicious transactions any transaction
should be beneficial for both
participants if the exchange office
seems too good to be true then it
probably is we shouldn't agree to it
there's a high probability of becoming a
victim to a fraudster and by the way i
think this rule should be remembered
more often by everybody not just
children at the end of 2020 adopt me
developers redesigned the pet exchange
mechanism they added history of
transactions warning about unequal
exchange and complicated the withdrawal
of money
do you think there's less fraud in the
game now no not according to what i've
read new schemes of deception have
appeared fishing links and even fake pet
sales sites have come into play
it's just like the real world now while
i was tinkering around with my first and
last pets in adopt me i was struck by
the ease with which the avatars of the
children entered into conversations with
each other i was constantly approached
by random strangers with requests
suggestions and sometimes just for chat
so look we decided to conduct a bit of a
small experiment here in the game i
began to approach unfamiliar people and
strike up conversations now i said that
the j from my nickname means jack that
i'm actually nine years old and was
interested in their names and ages now
four of the five people answered me and
were ready to continue the conversation
now imagine this in real life
surely you're not teaching your children
to talk with strangers are you
my observations were confirmed by the
report the malaysian communications and
multimedia commission it claims that
every fourth child agreed to meet in the
real world with a new friend from the
network but why don't such basic rules
apply in the virtual world
well children don't understand that
they're actually in the territory of
adults they're sure that a funny avatar
hides just a child like them and the
world of roblox is their universe in
which adults simply don't exist like a
neverland
[Music]
and yet despite social networks and
smartphones children still feel lonely
they need communication approval of
others
reaction to their actions and for adults
well communication is just a tool that
we've learned how to use and with the
help of conversations we solve specific
tasks the communication process itself
is very important for children and
really shouldn't be underestimated do
you remember the amazing success of
among us well its recipe is obvious
short sessions and vivid emotions from
communicating with other people some of
whom most of whom you haven't met before
well roblox gives everything the same
but instead of one game it offers 20
million new kinds of games now i
registered just a few hours ago and a
girl named samantha has already been
added to my friends i don't know who she
is but i can see her friend list of over
200 and many of them like samantha
herself clearly ignored the ban on using
real names when registering on roblox
well not only them
look this is another popular tower of
hell game the goal is very simple you
have until the round is over to get to
the top of said tower what interests me
here is not the gameplay but the list of
participants in the right corner of the
screen you see about half of the players
use real names in their nicknames
criminals take advantage of this firstly
they collect as much information as they
can about their victim from open sources
careless parents share details of their
children and their children's lives on
instagram or facebook plaster it over
the internet for everybody to see every
fourth child gets on the internet before
they're born expectant mothers are
posting ultrasound images on their pages
i've certainly seen that more than one
time and this phenomenon is so massive
that the term sheranting has appeared
for it
even innocent pictures against the
background of a school or kindergarten
can lead to tragedy
these can be used to find out additional
details about your child's life which
means it will be easier for a criminal
to gain their trust and exploit them in
a financial sense
now with the same methods of social
engineering a criminal can become your
child's best friend in a matter of weeks
and then it depends all on the
attacker's goals at best he will try to
steal the credit card details or maybe
try to steal an identity and at worst
your child might face some kind of
harassment but we're not going to go
down that route today
criminals often act in stages gradually
increasing their demands over time at
first they're going to communicate with
the child then they provoke an exchange
of secrets they reveal their invented
secrets and in response ask for the same
of the child this secret becomes the
basis for blackmail in exchange for it
the attacker asks for a relatively
innocent photo which he then uses
against the teenager
now this is a monstrously despicable
crime but you must warn your children
about it the chance of encountering
something like grooming online as this
type of crime is called is much higher
than actually meeting a pedophile on the
next street according to the us
department of justice 13 of teenagers
have experienced sexual harassment on
the internet
13 percent of course the creators of
roblox are also aware of the problem the
correspondence in the chats is monitored
by special programs if they notice that
certain words and expressions appear in
the correspondence then moderators come
into play they check messages and take
preventative measures
up to a lifetime ban of a suspicious
individual but look you can't have a
perfect program so get yourself an
account on roblox and check through your
child's friend list don't be afraid to
discuss the behavior of virtual friends
and the child will tell you everything
you need to know himself or herself and
also let him or her get familiar with
using the complain and report violence
buttons
in the virtual world they work extremely
effectively
[Music]
you know recently i came across a
curious study its authors claim that
over the past 50 years the world
accessible to american children has
decreased by 90 now if a 1970s teenager
could travel a few miles from home alone
then in 2020 the radius of his
independent movements is measured simply
in tens of yards
in my country the situation is very
similar in the 70s 80 percent of third
graders went to school on foot now only
one child out of 10 is allowed to do
this
for good or not we have begun to pay
much more attention to the safety of our
children some older people even call it
overprotective and call for giving
teenagers more freedom
it is all the more surprising that in a
digital space we take care of our
children much less according to
developer statistics 60 of parents set
restrictions on watching videos and
games are limited only in half of the
cases unfortunately in most cases even
advanced parental control systems give
only the illusion of security to the
parents on the other hand the future
belongs to them the alpha generation and
it's hardly worth imposing the old rules
of behavior on those who unlike you know
the history of 4 nn1 and what vault 8166
is a child is a beam of sunlight from
the infinite and eternal with
possibilities of both virtue and vice
but as yet unstained
my name is bradley and thanks for
joining us i'll see you next video
[Music]
you